Ramona mentioned in a QA i believe it
was for the asian film festival in san
diego that there was this circle of
trust around and at first you guys were
over in no man's land yeah then inst
your way in yes and that sometimes
whether it was maybe you or Ramona would
be allowed in certain certain situations
but not the camera people how did you
gain that trust is it is there's no
recipe for it it's just over time it's
just one on one as I was subscribed to
us by security it was a very big moment
when me a Ramona will never forget as
Chuck said this is the band this is the
circle of trust and this is you guys um
I would say you know we jumped over wood
when they were on the east coast our
first stop was Virginia Beach then we
went up to New York and you eat so we
did the East Coast venues with them and
then we went to the Midwest I think that
was probably all relationship building
um you know we got a lot of doors showed
on us because although they agreed to
have us on and they were very kind I
don't think they realize what that meant
you know so even if they weren't doing
anything and they're just sitting in
their dressing room we still wanted to
be there to document it and I don't
think they understood that I think they
were thinking more like you know we were
in a news crew that comes in for two
days and does a cool little piece and
the leaves and Ramona ways to Ramona
always tells the story Ramona always
tells a story that Nia looked up looked
up at her one time it's just sort of
like you're still here and she's like
yeah meal we're going to be here like
we're here so yeah that it took us a
while and like you said there's no
recipe it's just like a day by day by
day
and when we got when we first we started
we didn't even have badges then we got
badges and we thought we were good and
then we realized the badges didn't
really mean anything it was very limited
access you had to have a gold star on
your badge to get anywhere so finally we
had worked at work than got Ramona got
the gold star so she went into the
dressing room with like all the
confidence and swagger and she felt like
I got it in a bag now and they slammed
the door on the crew because the crew
did have a gold badge alright so we had
to work to get the crew but eventually
it worked out like I said they were
always kind I think they just didn't
realize the amount of time we were going
to be spending with them and what they
had signed out for
you